j'ai sept enfants dont trois qui sont
devenus autistes
maintenant que j'ai étudié davantage de
choses sur la vaccination je comprends
qu'il ya un lien entre cet autisme et la
vaccination des vidéos contre les
vaccins il y en a énormément sur
internet
l'argument c'est souvent oui ce point
naturel on sait pas ce que ton genre
pourquoi mettre de l'aluminium sinon
pour intoxiquer les populations alors
est ce que c'est vrai sait-on seulement
ce qu'il y à vraiment dans les vaccins
qu'on nous injecte parce que moi je ne
sais pas pour vous et je connais plus la
liste des ingrédients derrière un paquet
de serial que celle d'un vaccin avec ma
tarte on va étudier le rôle de chaque
ingrédient et voir quelle est la cause
des problèmes induits par la vaccination
vous allez voir c'est fascinant qu'est
ce qu'il ya dans un vaccin
vous connaissez le principe du vaccin
oprean virus on le désactive est enclin
gect techniquement oui un vaccin c'est
une piqûre de virus mort mais ça marche
votre corps détecte le virus ultra
fiable y apprend le combattre et quentin
le vrai virus balèze qui arrive un
système immunitaire est déjà prêt pour
lui [ __ ] une grosse raclée
ici le virus atténué le composant
thérapeutique du vaccin
maintenant on vire et satee nuit pour le
transporter il faut principalement de
l'eau oui techniquement de l'eau et rien
de plus mais voilà un vaccin c'est un
produit industriel
donc oui il existe bien des usines à
vaccin d'ailleurs ça ressemble à ça un
cadeau comme pour tbl uta pastabox le
produit doit être conservée transporter
puis vendues il faut donc éviter que ça
dégrade et c'est pour ça qu'on ajoute
plein d'autres éléments chimiques
j'avais raison les vaccins c'est pas bio
oui alors non heureusement que ces trucs
soi-disant nos cibles sont là d'abord
les conservateurs le vaccin contre la
dengue dans le corps donc vaut mieux que
ça soit pur et sans bactéries en 1916
des centaines d'enfants vaccinés contre
la typhoïde ont été contaminés par un
staphylocoque qui s'étaient développés
dans le liquide du vaccin
les conservateurs sont justement là pour
éviter ça avant les années 2000 un de
ces conservateurs était le thiomersal et
ce qui est pas cool avec lui c'est qu'il
contient du mercure toxiques
même si les études ont montré que ce
n'était pas dangereux à doses aussi
infimes par prudence ce n'est plus
utilisés aujourd'hui
enfin presque on en trouve encore dans
les anti venin est vraiment quelques
rares vaccin old school contre la grippe
aujourd'hui les conservateurs sont plus
naturelles par exemple 2 phénoxyéthanol
qu'on retrouve dans le thé vert ou la
chicorée les insecticides aussi deuxième
ingrédient les stabilisant les
stabilisants eux vont servir à maintenir
la qualité du vaccin et c'est pas des
produits terrifiant on parle de sucre de
lait de blanc d'oeuf et de gélatine
alors je sais vous n'avez pas envie de
vous piquer avec de l'actimel mais les
deux sont infimes
c'est juste pour que les virus du vaccin
soit bien troisième ingrédient les
agents in activateur comme on vous le
dit les vaccins ça reste quand même des
virus donc certains vaccins pour éviter
qu'ils se réveillent commencent à se
multiplier puis à [ __ ] le sbbl on va
ajouter un produit pour le calmer direct
commence à me parler poliment le produit
un activateur par excellence est
malheureusement très controversé c'est
un cancérigène avéré le formaldéhyde
alors si vous voulez un nom qui fais moi
peur c'est le formol le liquide pour
conserver des animaux morts bon bah on
en trouve absolument partout même le
corps en produits à tel point que l'air
que nous respirons est saturé de cette
substance
c'est l'un des produits polluants numéro
un dans l'ère des maisons y en a aussi
dans certains vaccins mais bon tellement
moins que dans tout ce que vous
trouverez autour de vous donc inutile de
paniquer quatrième ingrédients les
excipients
et c'est là que ça commence à chauffer
le but des excipients et de renforcer
l'efficacité des vaccins
il ya des vaccins quand tu les injecte
le corps ils paniquent pas trop du oui
bon virus
havas mais si on met des éléments
agressive dans le vaccin
le corps va se mettre dans un état d'
d'inflammation la panique générale
tout un système immunitaire va débouler
sur le champ de bataille
s'entraîner contrôle faux virus et c'est
là que le vaccin va être efficace à la
base pour les excipients on utiliser un
peu n'importe quoi comme des miettes de
pain ou du tapioca je suis sérieux en
injecter du tapioca pour remplacer ça on
a trouvé quelque chose de très très
efficace qui marche super bien elle et
l'aluminium
l'aluminium c'est un métal lourd comme
le mercure le plomb le corps l'éliminent
très bien mais quand même une petite
partie qui va rester dans les eaux le
foie et les poumons et c'est ça qui
inquiète
sauf que bon on injecte pas du papier
d'alu en réalité c'est une autre
molécule cette molécule
c'est du sels d'aluminium et le sel
d'aluminium il y en a plein de
différentes identités d'aluminium
phosphate d'aluminium ce le fait
d'aluminium chlorhydrate d'aluminium et
cetera et cetera celui utilisé dans les
vaccins c'est surtout l'hydroxyde
d'aluminium lui il est présent dans la
nature sous forme de roches comme la
pierre d'alun que vous connaissez
sûrement comme cosmétique
si vous avez déjà mis du déodorant ce
que j'espère sachez le vous avez pris la
maxi doses de sel d'aluminium
car oui l'aluminium ça fait peur mais
c'est un des éléments les plus abondants
de la couche terrestre
fatalement on en trouve un peu partout
dans tout ce que vous mangez même dans
le lait maternel
si vous donner un biberon de lait
industriel vous donner autant de sel
d'aluminium que ce qu'il y a dans un
vaccin injecté de l'aluminium en
quantités aussi un film n'a donc rien de
criminel
quels sont les effets secondaires
dangereux des vaccins on l'a vu dans la
partie précédente
oui les vaccins ont déjà tué le cas le
plus impressionnant c'est l'accident de
cutter encore aujourd'hui c'est
considéré comme l'un des plus grands
désastres pharmaceutique de l'histoire
des états unis
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en 1955
les vaccins du laboratoire cutter contre
la polio contenait la polio les virus
sont fait être désactivée ne l'était pas
vraiment plus de 40000 infections des
bébés mort-nés des paralysies des décès
ça a été une catastrophe
mais voilà aujourd'hui les normes de
sécurité des vaccins sont drastiques
plus de staphylocoques qui traînent plus
de virus non désactivé et pourtant
certaines personnes semblent encore mal
réagir aux vaccins premier cas douleur
et paralysie
imaginez vous venez de vous faire
vacciner contre l'hépatite b et un
simple vaccin une formalité mais soudain
vous commencez à vous sentir fatigué
vous avez mal aux muscles aux
articulations perdre la mémoire
qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'on
appelle une mie ofas it à macrophages
le premier cas a été détecté en 1996
avec comme premier suspect le sel
d'aluminium dans les vaccins
sauf qu'on est sûr de rien en fait on
n'est même pas sûr que cette maladie
existe en effet au total on observe le
phénomène que sur 400 personnes est
quasiment qu'en france ça serait donc
une maladie française
bizarre par exemple syndrome de
guillain-barré
c'est une grave maladie neurologique qui
entraîne des paralysies et peut être
parfois fatales il est provoqué par une
dysfonction du système immunitaire c'est
suffisant pour que quelques paranoïaque
sûrs sur tous les toits que les vaccins
en sont la cause
un premier groupe de chercheurs a montré
en 1976 que le risque d'attraper le
syndrome de guillain-barré après avec
saint était un chouïa plus élevé puis
entre 2000 et 2009
une autre étude a montré qu'au contraire
les vaccins nous en protège ray un peu
d'où l'idée que la cause pourrait être
ailleurs que dans les vaccins et son
aluminium peut-être une allergie à
l'aluminium
le problème c'est qu'on sait pas trop
par quoi remplacer le sel d'aluminium
le candidat numéro 1 c'est le phosphate
de calcium mais il reste moins
performant que l'aluminium
en tout cas c'est ce qu'en disent les
labos qui a énormément de flou son sujet
et c'est normal on veut pas créer
mouvement de panique
si les gens arrêtent de se vacciner par
peur on se limitera pas à 2 3 4 fatigue
c'est des millions de victimes
potentielles
deuxième cas l'autisme c'est une phobie
qui persistent dans l'imaginaire
collectif
l'idée que les vaccins provoquent
l'autisme née d'un énorme scandale qui
s'est déroulé dans les années 1988
des chercheurs avec une masse d'études
sur des milliers d'enfants ont réussi à
prouver que le coupable de l'autisme
étaient les vaccins attendues 10 vaste
étude
ah ben non ils ont examiné des enfants
l'étude est porté par un certain andrew
wakefield et son travail ne dit
absolument pas que c'est lié juste que
c'est possible ça aurait pu s'arrêter là
mais une fois publié là
sheen médiatique s'embrase et ou aux
fils de 100 kg il s'empresse d'organiser
des conférences de presse
et devinez ce qui dit il y à un ré lien
entre l'autisme et l'abattît nation la
nouvelle est jeté aux lions
c'est le départ d'un incendie qui mettra
des années à s'éteindre parce qu'en fait
tout est faux bah ouais on a quand même
refait une étude pour vérifier au
danemark entre 1999 et 2010 ces six
mille cinq cents enfants qui ont
développé des troubles autistiques
les chercheurs ont alors comparer le
nombre d'enfants autistes parmi les
vaccinés et parmi les non vaccinés
résultat pas de différence aucune étude
n'est parvenu à mettre en lumière un
quelconque lien entre autisme et
vaccination tout ce que vous avez
entendu sur l'autisme et les vaccins sa
part de ça de cette étude bidon le
journal ayant publié ces mêmes rétracter
et excusé auprès de la communauté
scientifique
dix ans après la publication mais bon
c'était déjà ça wakefield a été interdit
de pratiquer la médecine au royaume uni
et un même été rognées par ses pairs pas
le choix il a immigré aux états unis
alors pourquoi on voit qu'il a fait ça
la thune juste la thune probablement pas
la gloire peut-être d'avoir fait une
grande découverte et d'être enfin
reconnu mais surtout là dessus parce que
faut pas oublier que le gars a été payé
par un cabinet d'avocats mandatés par
les familles de leur foi aux pistes afin
de leur faire gagner un procès contre
les fabricants de vaccins
le truc c'est qu'un procès contre les
grands laboratoires ça peut rapporter
gros
par exemple procès contre les
laboratoires pour les victimes du
médiator
ces 115 millions de dollars
d'indemnisation le médiator était
prescrit pour des victimes de diabète de
niveau 2 mais aussi comme coupe faim et
pour des millions de personnes
ça s'est très mal passé a du coup il y
avait de l'argent à se faire déjà
wakefield avait constitué une société
dans le but de commercialiser des tests
et il prévoyait d'en tirer 72,5 millions
de livres par an au royaume uni et aux
usa soutenu par donald trump et de
nombreuses autres victimes
wakefield reçoit un fort soutien
financier lui permettant de mettre leur
cause sous le feu des projecteurs
du coup qui est le comploteur dans
l'histoire plutôt les laboratoires ou
plutôt les millionnaires soutenu par le
président des états unis
troisième cas l'affaiblissement
génétique sachez le
l'adn humain
et en partie virale nous vivons car nous
avons des virus en nous il y à 50
millions d'années un animal a été
infecté par un virus
il l'a intégré en lui ce virus dans son
adn lui a donné la possibilité de
fabriquer la protéine à l'origine du
placenta le plat s'entasser le liquide
qui vous a permis de vous développer
dans le ventre de votre mère sans ce
virus pas de place en t'as pas un
mammifère donc pas d'humains ces virus
dans notre adn ne provoque pas de
maladie
ils sont non pathogène mais peut-être
qu'à un moment de l'histoire il l'était
c'était peut-être la grippe de l'époque
qui a permis d'améliorer le matériel
génétique des humains c'est là la
théorie soutenue par certains en
empêchant les virus on empêche
l'évolution fer tombe lui se nourrir des
milliers de gens on participe à une
certaine sélection naturelle les plus
forts survivent mais est ce que c'est
vraiment le genre d'idéologie qu'on veut
encore en 2020 pas sûr alors oui la
vaccination n'est pas parfaite
il y à des risques et des effets
secondaires comme n'importe quel
médicament ou opérations médicales
ce qui est dingue c'est que la france
est reconnue pour avoir une des
meilleures médecine au monde mais aussi
une des plus grandes communautés anti
vaccins et vous quel est votre avis sur
les vaccins laisser un petit commentaire
pour partager votre opinion
pensez à vous abonner si vous souhaitez
toujours plus de vidéos de séances
merci à spike pour les recherches
s'étaient pas facile c'est un sujet
quand même assez dense assez chaud et
faut pas dire de bêtises
ce que j'espère qu'on n'a pas fait
normalement sa morale et merci de nous
avoir suivis allez les amis